embark on a bold new journey in rising
tide the upcoming expansion to
civilization beyond Earth rising tide
introduces new ways to explore colonize
and conquer as you shape a new vision
for Humanity on an alien planet the
remaining survivors of Earth fell in a
vicious power struggle for the planets
last remaining resources from this
turmoil new factions arose and took to
the stars in search of new worlds to
call their own
one such faction is Alfa la led by the
cunning RC Ashish Alpha la are a
determined and self-reliant people who
place community and brotherhood as chief
values of their society and strive to
uphold the honor of those that came
before them with new factions come new
technologies for the first time in a
civilization game you now have the
ability to expand your Dominion to the
seas build floating settlements harvest
new resources and command new units like
patrol boats and submarines as well as
enhanced amphibious versions of
explorers and colonists but expand
cautiously as ocean cities are more
susceptible to attacks from neighbouring
civilizations and sea creatures alike
deadly rippers and makaras lurk within
the ocean depths ready to strike while
the monstrous Hydra coral has the power
to stop armies in their tracks from the
depths of the vast oceans to the fiery
peaks of violent volcanoes rising tide
is breathing new life into the look and
feel of the worlds you will call home
new primordial worlds of fire and ash
present new challenges for civilizations
that must work together to build their
home in an otherwise inhospitable land
though harsh these new worlds contain
valuable artifacts to uncover artifacts
can be collected in a variety of ways
and can now be used to provide unique
benefits depending on whether they are
opened individually or used in groups to
unlock greater rewards this was just a
glimpse into the ever-changing landscape
of rising tide in part 2 we'll explore
additional factions new approaches to
diplomacy and trade and more of the
exciting new worlds found in
civilization beyond Earth rising tide
[Music]
you